Le parti communiste est encore communiste. Oui.
Il ne faut pas avoir de l'imitation
dans notre aide à l'Ukraine.
Si, 1 société communiste est 1 société idéale,
non. Je suis marxiste. Oui.
Les communistes et le Rassemblement National,
c'est presque pareil.
Non. L'Europe est sur le déclin.
Oui. Il faut réguler l'immigration au niveau européen
en partie.
L'Union européenne est 1 chance pour les agriculteurs
français. Oui et non.
La Chine,
voilà 1 exemple de communisme réussi. Non, pas du tout.
Les États-Unis sont les alliés naturels de l'Europe. Non,
les ouvriers ne votent plus pour les communistes.
Non,
les élections européennes peuvent changer les choses.
Oui, l'Ukraine a son avenir dans l'Union européenne. Non,
la guerre à Gaza est 1 génocide.
Oui, les vieux partis sont morts.
Non, le clivage gauche droite a disparu. Non,
il faut davantage t'accélérer riche.
Oui, le parti communiste aurait dû changer de nom.
Non. L'Union européenne est 1 réussite.
Non. Vladimir putin est 1 Criminal de guerre.
Oui, l'écologie doit être 1 priorité dans la politique
européenne. Oui.